Speaker 1: We have been following what has been
I mean, at this point, has it been seven or eight
different dates on which Donald Trump was
supposedly going to be the winner of the
twenty twenty election in November? It was by
December. This thing's all going to be sorted out
in December. It was definitely by January 20. By
January 6th, it's going to be sorted out after
January 6th. That was definitely by January 20th.
Then it became March. Most recently it is August.
And one of the big purveyors or perpetrators of
the completely bogus idea that Donald Trump will
be reinstated as president in August is the My
Pillow CEO, Mike Lyndell, known to some as Mike
Pillow. Donald Trump has been reportedly pushing
this himself, as reported by The New York Times,
Washington Post and National Review that he
would be reinstated as president in August.
The Constitution provides no mechanism for such
reinstatement. It's impossible. If Joe Biden were
unable to be president for whatever reason, it
would go to the vice president and subsequently
the speaker of the House. You don't say, let's
go back to the last guy. But my pillow founder
and CEO Mike Lendell, after weeks and weeks of
saying it will be August, is now shifting to say,
well, it actually could be September. Here he
is yesterday on one program now saying August,
September. OK, well, we're going to see
Speaker 2: now, do you believe that
Trump will still be back in office before
long? Yeah, I think I've said August, but
with the timing, I moved everything out because
I, you know, at some point symposium and stuff.
Speaker 1: And does anybody know what symposium
he's talking about? I'm not aware. I don't
even know that he knows what symposium
means. Never mind. There was one, but OK.
Speaker 2: And you know this. I know. I know it's
going to be you know, they're going to pull this
down. They they won't have a choice because of
the evidence. But, you know, there's different
things they're doing. I've said August that could
be off by a month, could be September. I believe
it's going to be this fall for sure.
Speaker 1: So now we've got
it. It's August. It could be September. But it'll
definitely be the fall which fall gets us until
I mean, technically that winter doesn't start
until December 20th, 20th and 21st. Right.
So so now it's already getting pushed. And
he's saying this on multiple shows. Here's
another one from the last couple of days.
Speaker 2: They pulled this selection down
and it's over. You put our real president back in.
But I think I think the mainstream media, like you
said, August excuse me, I might be off by a month.
Speaker 1: So there it is again. He might be off
by just one month. And as a reminder, don't
forget, he was definitively saying August for
a really long time. Let's take a listen to that.
Speaker 2: What I'm talking about, Steve,
is when I have been doing since January
9th, all the evidence I have, everything is
going to go before the Supreme Court and the
election of twenty twenty is going bye bye.
It was an attack by another country, communism
coming in. I don't know what they're going to
do with what after they pull it down.
Speaker 1: But what's he even talking
about communism coming in? I
don't even know what that means.
Speaker 2: Hang on. Hang on a sec. Donald
Trump could go back in office in August,
Speaker 1: so that was even too wacky for Steve
Bannon. That last clip was from Steve Bannon show
and Steve even saying, oh, my God, I've got to
control this guy. Slow down here. Let me ask you
more questions. And Mike Lyndell would not be
would not be distracted. So what's the reality
of what's going on here? This is a grift. That's
that's all it is. It's a grift for Trump, for Mike
Lyndell. You know, he organized this rally a few
weeks ago and he's getting attention. And I guess
he sort of enjoys it. But this is almost certainly
going to become, well, fall and it's going to
be early in twenty, twenty two. And then it's
just going to be, hey, you know what, guys? We
we didn't get the Supreme Court to do what we said
they were going to do. We didn't get this other
court. We didn't get this other court. We just
have to vote now. We just have to vote and make
sure that strong supporters of Donald Trump win
in November of twenty two. That is what it will
become. We've been saying it for months at this
point in time, and then it will become we need to
do this in order for Trump twenty twenty four and
money will be raised and people will spend money
on this nonsense and they will be bamboozled
as they have been for a really long time now.
Yesterday when I interviewed psychiatrist
Orlock Kanojia, we talked about what what is
it for Trump supporters that has prevented them
from getting beyond the denial stage of grief?
And he said, you know, it's tough to say as a
group, I'd have to talk to them individually
and that was an astute answer and a logical
one, because when these people call me,
some of them are simply in denial about the facts
of what took place, whereas others don't focus as
much on bamboo fibers in Arizona and massive
dumps in Michigan or whatever the case may be.
And it's more about the evils of Joe Biden and
the sort of the ends justify the means less about.
I can't really articulate exactly how Biden stole
it, but Biden's a communist, Biden's a socialist.
Biden is a Marxist. And so it's justified to do
whatever we can do to put Trump back in power,
even if we can't really make the case
that the election was actually stolen.
And then I do think that for a non-zero
number, it's also sort of like a mental
illness thing that's going on. Certainly some
of the folks that have called into my show
at a very colloquial level without diagnosing
anybody, they don't seem in touch with reality.
And I wouldn't be surprised if they have other
completely nonsense based conspiracy theories
about covid vaccines would be a top contender
for sure, but possibly in other areas as well. So
it's not happening in August. It's not happening
in September. It's not happening by the end of
the fall and the start of winter. But they will
smoothly transition into we need to donate now
so that friends of Trump can win in twenty twenty
two and impeach Joe Biden and get Trump back in
that way, which won't happen. Which won't happen.
That will get them to twenty twenty for the
twenty twenty four campaign will probably start
in twenty three and that's going to be the next
three and a half years. That seems to be very
clearly the direction that all of this is going.
If you see it differently, I want to hear from
you. You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman